depuis la loi du 15 juin 2000 la
protection juridique de ce principe
cardinal le plat procédure pénale n'a
cessé d'être améliorée par les lois
subséquentes et pourtant les attentes
sont devenus de plus en plus gras mais
de plus en plus nombreuses en atteignant
une ampleur
sans précédent depuis le milieu des
années 2000 c'est à dire depuis
l'émergence des réseaux sociaux
alors
là on connaît bien les raisons pour
lesquelles ce principe très important
qui est un des principes fondateurs de
notre état de droit qui remonte pas
seulement d'ailleurs à la déclaration à
l'article 9 bien connu de la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen qui
remonte bien avant à des juristes du
droit canon avait déjà évoqué sa onzième
au 14e siècle le roi louis saez lui-même
788 avait prononcé des mots très forts
le site dans le rapport en faveur de la
présomption d'innocence
donc c'est un principe un concept ancien
qui a été constamment réaffirmées par
alors après la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et des citoyens mais par tous
les grands textes internationaux aussi
bien européens que mondiaux
or
les difficultés de l'application sont
multiples d'abord parce que si c'est un
principe extrêmement important cardinal
même c'est un principe qui n'est pas
absolue il doit être conciliée avec
d'autres principes de valeurs normatives
équivalentes sont par exemple la liberté
d'expression où les droits des victimes
les droits de la défense pour ça que
c'est très heureuse que basile ader qui
a participé au groupe de travail que
j'ai constitué
qui en a été un des éléments les plus
actifs et soit venu avec moi aujourd'hui
vous ayez accepté monsieur le président
parce que je pense que c'est très
important d'avoir le point de vue de
d'un avocat spécialisé dans le droit de
la presse qui défend le droit de la
presse car souvent on ne pose évidemment
présomption d'innocence et liberté
d'expression or toute la difficulté est
d'arriver à concilier ses principes avec
d'autres encore une fois et ce l'office
du juge bien entendu
et ça revient sur d'un lieu à des
interprétations
soit du juge national soit du juge soit
du juge européen qui s'impose ensuite
au enfin tous les acteurs de la société
et c'est vrai que l'évolution
jurisprudentielle
notamment au niveau de la cour
de justice européenne
des cours de justice a fait que la
balance penche de plus en plus vers la
liberté d'expression alors moi je ne
m'en plaindrai pas parce que je pense
que c'est un trésor c'est ça nous impose
et la jurisprudence de la cour de
cassation respectueuse heureusement et
du conseil constitutionnel aussi
respectueux de
la primauté du droit européen sur le
droit de la sionneau
intègre donc le jurisprudence nationale
naturellement c'est
l'esprit et la lettre de ces arrêts
européens
alors voilà quelle est la situation
aujourd'hui
je considère que dans
depuis donc une vingtaine d'années au
fond dans la conciliation car c'est plus
difficile entre la protection de la
présomption d'innocence et
et la liberté d'expression grosso modo
la presse classique traditionnelle c'est
attention voilà nous n'avons plus
vraiment il ya des dérapages
mais nous n'avons plus
et scandale aussi retentissant que nous
analysons dans le rapport en donnant la
référence de tous les articles de presse
un des scandales ou si retentissant que
le traitement par exemple par un par une
certain par la presse à l'époque c'était
au début des années 2000 de grands
accidents collectifs comme la sphère
furiani fondremand de la tribune
assure yannick tribunes du stade où l'
affaire azf à toulouse nous analysons
puisque c'était la première demande du
garde des sceaux d'analyser la porte et
la nature des attaques ou nous analysons
que danser danser grand
catastrophe collective évidemment les
investigations sont très longs c'est une
multitude des partys
et que l'émotion est évidemment à son
comble
c'est très long et donc le contexte se
prête au fond à des mises en cause
active qui se sont révélés d'ailleurs
c'est bon dans ces deux cas non
seulement à fonder non seulement
personne ne râle mais aussi de personnes
physiques en réalité ce que tout ce
travail m'a confirmé en tout cas c'est
que il ya là une bataille
juridique et politique
fondamentale a mené parce que les grands
principes de nos têtes à droite dans le
débat public c'est par vous élus de la
nation que je vais apprendre ça sont
systématiquement sapée je suis alarmé et
accablé par l'évolution du débat public
en france qui en vient à contester non
seulement l'autorité des décisions de
cours européennes
primauté admise par tous les
gouvernements de et président de la vème
république depuis le début
qui contestent même les décisions du
conseil constitutionnel peut toujours
discuter une décision mais contestées on
peut toujours changer le droit
d'ailleurs l'état du droit peut être
modifiée par des majorités mais l'état
de droit ça c'est autre chose c'est un
ensemble de principes de valeurs
tétanise qui a été consacrée encore une
fois dans notre pays depuis très
longtemps et nous avons là des
expressions publiques y compris hélas
deux personnalités qui font que
jusqu'ici 20 qui avait
manifesté un engagement européen sans
faille je trouve ça extrêmement
alarmants et la présomption d'innocence
n'est pas évidemment le seul principe
qui est menacée je crois que nous avons
là un enjeu
sociétal politique majeure et que
[Musique]
nous devons évidemment
tous et toutes faire ce qui est en notre
pouvoir pour tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
merci beaucoup merci mais la miss
peut-être quelques mots monsieur basile
ader a donc est avocat au barreau de
paris ancien bâtonnier de l'ordre et
puis ensuite je n'aurais parole à des
collègues qui ont déjà demandé à
s'exprimer
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
président on va ça va être très rapide
parce que même le ministre à helle dit
me semble t-il tout ce qu'il fallait
dire mais si je tentais de résumer était
lentement pour ce qui pourrait vous
préoccupez vous qui êtes faisait la loi
et ce qui pourrait être encore à fait ou
améliorés
sous le double angle
d atteinte qu'on peut causer à la
présomption d'innocence qui d'abord
consiste à ne pas traiter quelqu'un
comme innocent alors qu'il n'a pas été
encore jugé définitivement coupable est
donc là ça intéresse l'autorité
judiciaire nous faisons quelques
propositions par exemple termine
terminologique il y a dans le code pénal
le code de procédure pénale souvent le
mot victime
qui semble désigner quelqu'un comme déjà
vite me reconnu judiciairement comme
victime alors qu'elle n'est que
plaignante ou partie civile sur doute là
il y aurait-il un petit toilettage à
faire nous sommes interrogé aussi sur la
question de la présence de la la
détention provisoire qui est un peu trop
rapidement la règle alors on sait les
contraintes qu'on les juge les jld et à
des groupes progrès qui ont été faits
depuis la loi du 15 juin 2000 mais sont
houleux sans doute faut-il faire un peu
de réflexion à ce sujet et et tenter
d'améliorer les choses et puis
évidemment le sujet principal est la
justification d'ailleurs eu de la part
du garde des sceaux de d'avoir confié à
madame guigou le soin de réfléchir à
nouveau puisque sa loi effet
considérablement progresser les choses
vingt ans plus tôt
c'est les atteintes liée à la
présentation publique de quelqu'un comme
étant coupable alors qu'il ne l'est pas
encore juger définitivement
qui est d'abord eu une
atteinte au procès équitable
c'est-à-dire qu'on c'est quelqu'un qui
est présenté comme coupable publiquement
va nécessairement
même à son corps défendant amené le juge
avoir un traitement un peu différent
mu qu'il est ou influencer qui peut
l'être par l'opinion publique qui se va
se dégager de cette présentation
publique et donc ça ça nous a pas
échappé et puis évidemment il ya la
question de l'atteinte à la réputation
et à l'instrumentalisation qui peut être
fait sur les réseaux sociaux parce
qu'évidemment comme vient de le dire
madame guigou ça a pris une ampleur
considérable parce que le principe du
réseau social c'est que c'est le
scandale
qui rencontrent un écho public
donc il ya un jeu très pervers à
présenter quelqu'un comme quoi pas parce
qu'on sait que cette présentation la
varende rencontrer tout de suite un écho
beaucoup plus important que la
rectification y compris judiciaires qui
elle n'intéressera pas et donc là on a
fait une réflexion je le dis tout de
suite auprès des réseaux sociaux parce
qu'ils ont les moyens d'intelligence
artificielle
pour amener chez tous les internautes
qui se sont intéressés à un moment ou un
autre soit parce qu'ils ont mis à
l'arrêt soit parce qu'ils ont partagé il
soit parce qu'eux mêmes ils ont visionné
quelques mines tout ça ils le savent
pour faire en sorte que le message qui
doit être apportée qui viendraient
réparer ou commencé de réparer
l'atteinte à la présomption d'innocence
soit également apporter à tous ceux qui
ont vu le message initial est donc là il
ya une vraie réflexion et un combat mais
je m'en dire un petit mot pour terminer
et puis il ya question de la
méconnaissance de l'institution
judiciaire et là ça nous apparaît
flagrant vous venez de le dire un
problème d'éducation un problème de
déficit de communication de la part de
l'institution judiciaire qui n'est pas
formé pour ça qui est d'ailleurs
traditionnellement
aînés de la justice l'ancien régime qui
étaient par nature secrète soul et donc
les vieux réflexes d'un juge et de ne
pas parler
car effectivement souvent il s'expose
alors la loi guigou avait instauré le
procureur la république comme
l'informateur officiels et des dossiers
au moment où l'émotion publique est à
son comble les fausses informations
ça pouvait paraître curieux que ce soit
suite il porte l'accusation qu'ils
soient l'informateur officielle mais on
s'est rendu compte que finalement c'est
c'est c'est le moins mauvais des
systèmes à défaut de pouvoir de la part
des avocats avoir accès au dossier de
pouvoir communiquer de leur côté parce
que dit il communiqua l'aveuglent
et puis la question du secret de
l'enquêté et de l'instruction sur lequel
nous avons beaucoup débattu
effectivement
j'étais étonnant puisque vous l'avez
rappelé je me dis stop suis absolument
pas des conclusions du rapport mais il
me semblait que à partir du moment où on
est aux phases la phase de l'instruction
c'était le procès avait commencé la mise
en cause des suspects avait commencé il
n'y avait plus de raison
d'imposer un quelconque secret qu'il il
fallait que on puisse surveiller ce qui
se passe et que c'était d'ailleurs
souvent la règle dans d'autres pays
notamment dans les systèmes anglosaxons
qu'évidemment il faut protéger l'anc est
bon pour des raisons techniques qui sont
au fait que l'instruction peut être
engagée alors même que l enquête
continue et qu'il ne faut pas perturber
celle ci ce n'est pas possible pour
autant nous faisons une avancée par
rapport à ce qu avait posé la loi du 15
juin 2000 sur ces fameuses fenêtre de
deux publicités dans les instances
devant la chambre de l'instruction voir
devant le jld lorsque le dossier a
inscrit un certain délai c'est dire
qu'il faut laisser quand même aux
enquêteurs une parfaite parfait secret
pour mener à bien leurs enquêtes
[Musique]